le président macron celle inverse du
cochon mais ça n'est pas du tout
flatteur
si le nom du président se prête bien à
la verve populaire lui même ne l'est
guère populaire aux yeux de tous ces
manifestants
depuis un an il fait une politique
totalement contraire aux intérêts de la
population des salariés des jeunes et
ses témoins bref l'ensemble des réformes
qu'ils mettent en place et nous notre
mode hot c'est macron un an ça suffit il
est en train de détruire tous les acquis
sociaux
il ya une cote de travail m'attend c'est
la fonction publique la sncf c'est pas
du tout possible que ça continue comme
ça jusqu'en 2022
la fronde est sur les rails et les
cheminots font bien sûr office de
locomotive dans les wagons une cargaison
de colère en tous genres hausse de la
csg pour les retraités baisse des aides
sociales sélection à l'université loi
sur les migrants ou encore asphyxie de
l'hôpital public
tout cela finit par faire pas mal de
gens qui n'ont plus envie de rigoler
paroles de claude j'en vois du monde qui
envoie du monde cas plus envie de rire
alors on est là pour ça tous ces mois en
grain avec les autres parce que si on
sépare qu'on est tous dans notre cour il
n'y arrivera pas tous ensemble c'est
comme ça qu'il faut faire mais au fait
d'où vient la manif d'aujourd'hui les
médias qui aime bien les stars 10 c'est
jean luc mélenchon mais c'est inexact
il faut rappeler qu'au départ c'est à
l'initiative des associations attac et
fondation copernic qui ont dès le 17
avril convié plusieurs organisations
qu'elles soient syndicales politiques ou
associatives à se réunir pour voir
comment analyser à partager les mêmes
analyses savoir sont partagés même
analyse de la politique du gouvernement
et du président macro et savoir comment
on pouvait avoir peut-être une
déclaration commune
chacun dans ses prérogatives qu'elle
soit syndicales politiques ou
associatives
100 manifestants et une journée plutôt
réussi il y en aura-t-il d'autres
personne n'en sait rien
[Musique]